the minivan was designed with families
in mind but it also revolutionized
travel for people in wheelchairs from
the outside the van will look no
different
but inside the modifications will be
major the total revamp starts with the
removal of the Vans middle and third row
seats they pull out the carpet and
completely strip the vehicle from the
front seats to the back underneath a
technician saws off the exhaust system
and disassembles the rear suspension the
entire undercarriage behind the engine
is about to be reconfigured to make way
for a new lowered floor the team also
removes the 20 gallon fuel tank they'll
replace it with one of the same capacity
to fit the new configuration they cut
out a large section of floor and
relocate displaced wiring they're now
ready to roll the new floor framework
into position below the vehicle this
steel structure replaces the original
one and is strong enough to support the
additional weight of a wheelchair a
motorized one can weigh as much as four
adults they slide the new steel floor
into the vehicle and lower it into the
framework
the new floor is significantly lower
than the one the van came with and it
increases the wheelchair passengers
Headroom by about 10 to 15 inches after
installing the new fuel tank suspension
and exhaust systems they return to the
interior a technician fits and binds
carpet under padding to the van with the
back of the van rebuilt and carpeted
they now ready the wheelchair ramp a
technician applies a gritty material
with an adhesive backing he simply
presses it to the ramp and smooths out
any air bubbles this gritty material
will provide a slip resistant surface
for the wheelchair to move across the
team then links the wheelchair ramp to
the new floor with a long hinge they
install stainless steel trim over the
hinge to protect it and also connect the
counterbalance cables to the ramp the
wheelchair converted van is now ready
for a test drive the operator unfolds
the ramp he folds away the new seats to
make way for the wheelchair
he extends the tie-down belts and
attaches them to the wheelchair he
wheels the passenger into the van locks
the wheelchair brakes and ties the chair
to the floor there are standard
seatbelts to fasten and then it's time
to sit back and enjoy the ride
seated in the converted minivan the
individual can now experience the
freedom of the road